khaldi mallet alors moi je comprends
évidemment isabelle que ce soit très
violent quand quelqu'un vous insulte
comme ça dans le supermarché comme vous
l'avez dit mais comprenez aussi que pour
le citoyen mais ouais il peut être
exaspéré mais je compte colère mais bien
sûr mais je le colle le grand politique
pourri le côté la marine auxonnais mois
mythique hors la loi non mais ça fait
partie aussi de tout ça mais je le
comprends de la soie karadic et vous
avez tout à fait raison je ne suis
absolument pas dans le déni
vous l'avez compris je dis très
clairement je n'ai pas du tout dans le
déni il voulait savoir est ce que vous
regrettez
est ce que ces dernières années ont été
complètement gâchée est-ce que vous avez
un regret aujourd'hui à mais j'ai un
regret c'est d'avoir fait cette faute
stupide elle est même pire que ça
d'avoir cédé aux espèce de chantage que
m'ont fait que m'a fait ma fratrie
mais je le regrette du fond du coeur
parce que j'ai pas été courageuse
voilà parce que j'aurais pas dû le faire
mais bien sûr que je regrette
ça nous a gâché toute notre vie isabelle
isabelle je sais qu'on se connaît et je
connais patrick également de toute la
famille moi je sais que vous aimez les
gens je sais que c'est ce que vient de
dire virale dean elle a raison je la
rejoins c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de
gens qui vous aimait énormément qui
croyant vous qui se disait si les gens
qui nous font du bien dans notre ville
et vous avez déçu pas mal de gens voient
là et on le dit c'est vrai c'est plus ça
je pense qu'ils vous qui vous pouvez dès
aujourd'hui que c'est certainement moins
vrai dans notre ville ouais que vous ne
le pensez c'est vrai à l'extérieur
justement pour des gens qui ne nous
connaissent pas mais c'est ça alors que
dans notre ville je peux vous dire que
aujourd'hui comme hier nous sommes chez
nous nous y sommes souvent et les gens
sont adorables et d'ailleurs pour tout
vous dire nous vivrons toujours à
levallois puisque la mort faisant partie
de la vie nous y avons nos tombeaux
réserve